what do you think should be done about
these girls can anything be done about
them at all they've gone they want to be
there and they're viewed as a potential
threat if they come back I think once
they've gone there's not much our
government can really do because
obviously we know there's a civil war
taking place in the country however if
they do want to come back I can
understand that some people feel that
they're a threat but there's a reason
that they want to come back and I think
when you have treason may say that they
will be allowed back into the country I
think what we're doing is closing doors
on British nationals if anything there's
a possibility we can bring them here and
encourage rehabilitation and use them as
example so that they can try to stop
other young people from going to Syria
do you think mr. Phillips that they pose
a threat threat and it's not only these
three that's the key point there there
are potentially hundreds of people in
the similar situation and it's going to
be very difficult for the police and the
security services in the UK if they do
come back but I mean what sort of threat
could 16 year old girls pose well of
course as we said in the in the audio of
the video that these people are being
trained and there are all sorts of
things that are going on in Iraq and
Syria that actually if those things were
brought to the streets of the UK it
would be a disaster and you know where
we have issues that have happened in the
past with people being attacked this
could be much worse for people that have
had a degree of training miss Coco that
have been reports that some of the
so-called chehade brides are now being
encouraged to be suicide bombers
but there's a lot of propaganda taking
place i know you've just shown report
about you know a girl fleeing from there
but we don't really know whether it's
authentic or not because Isis machine
this propaganda machine is very very
good so yes there may be threat but at
the same time if they are willing to
come back there's a reason they're
coming back if we're looking at 16 and
15 year olds they young growth the
children at the end of the day and young
kids make so many mistakes in life we
have to be able to you know provide them
the right services so that they can also
once they've learned from their mistakes
we provide them the right support
unfortunately we do know what Isis does
it seems by our bodies to be a pretty
appalling or organization executing
people carrying out suicide bombings and
bits of other appalling acts you know
you can't just say can you that people
have been exposed to that should come
back and be treated with tender loving
care well I think if we're going to
treat anyone who decides to come back
into this country or we go down the road
of not allowing anyone back in the
country we have to then apply the same
principle to other people other
nationals that go off to other groups
around the world for example you have
British nationals that go off to fight
for the IDF who is in essence killing
innocent Palestinians I mean I suppose
do you think this is a wider problem
what do you think this relates
specifically to people have gone out to
support is well I think the main
difference here is that these people
eventually are being told to come back
to the UK to attack their own country
now we do know of these three young
ladies and of course 6 15 16 year-old
girls are impressionable one of the
questions is how do we stop them going
in the first place but when they come
back if we only know of the ones that we
are we're aware of we have all sorts of
issues in tracking down and preventing
really serious offences happening on the
streets of the UK miss Coco what why do
you think the girls do want to go out I
mean after all before they go they'll
have seen Western coverage of what
going on what is attracting them to go
to what some people described as a death
cult you have different cases in some
cases with the younger ones it's a
grooming issue there's a lot of mistrust
with the government here when they do
see issues where you know like I
mentioned before Palestinians are being
massacred or now we've got the wrong guy
Muslims being butchered and the
government stay silent and in their eyes
their condoning that these actions so
you've become less impressed with your
own government because you feel guilty
that you know they're not doing enough
so it's easily brainwashing them into
these ideologies and then they think
that they have something in common with
Isis because they're fighting the same
cause if anything the government here
needs to put right solutions in place by
working with the Muslim community are
not constantly stigmatizing and
attacking the community I don't
understand that because Isis is a Muslim
organization which is killing fellow
Muslims Isis isn't terrorist
organization i think when we bring
religion into every single thing we're
actually tarnishing of religion Isis is
a terrorist organization just like
Israel as a terrorist state just like
there's other terrorist organizations so
we have to be very careful not to
constantly tarnish the religion well
you're the one who brought it up that's
because you're constantly talking about
the organization like that I just wanted
to make it very clear that the Muslim
community is constantly being either
asked to apologize for this organization
has nothing to do with the religion just
because they think that the Muslims it
doesn't mean that they represent or are
Muslims okay thank you very much indeed